the first latin americans to be
vaccinated against covid
nurses and doctors in mexico few would
argue with their place at the front of
the line
more medical staff have died here than
in any other country in the world
i'm going to feel much safer now at work
the truth is that we're really exposed
to all types of body fluids so having
the vaccine is really going to help
so far mexico's only received 3 000
doses
the line to get them snaked around the
block moore should arrive
each week they can't come soon enough
the mexican government is pretty
triumphant about the arrival of the
vaccine but it's not here in time
to save the country from its current
problems in the capital
the hospitals are almost full and now
there's very few ventilators available
for the population of one of the biggest
cities in the world
mexico city is now on red alert with all
but essential businesses closed
a group of nurses in the vaccination
queue told us how things were in their
hospital
we're completely full patients in
serious conditions on ventilators
[Music]
and a lot of deaths too about seven a
day at the moment
and a lot of people coming in from the
moment we start our morning shift
they and others of their colleagues were
nervous about any possible side effects
from the vaccine
but they said the benefits far outweigh
their concerns
sometimes we have to isolate and we want
to be with our family
i want to hug my grandmother and even
more at christmas
latin america a virus epicenter needed
some light at the end of the tunnel
this looks like it but vast segments of
the population won't be vaccinated for
months yet
at least it's a start john holman al
jazeera
mexico city